what are your what are your thoughts on
charlemagne the god
i interviewed him back in the day he's
definitely probably like one of the
people who's
shown us the heights that you can reach
through
being like a hip-hop media personality
for sure just seeing him do all this
crazy tv stuff and everything like i
mean
as somebody who's been watching him for
like 10 years i definitely did not know
that he had that in him but it's
definitely an inspiration for sure yeah
yeah i mean he's an impressive cat yeah
yeah well i like what he's doing
for mental health too
like that like i guess he somebody was
telling me that he
just came out and said dude i i go to
therapy like if you have problems go get
help go get on ssr go whatever you know
and don't keep that [ __ ] in and like
he's all about encouraging people to
like work that [ __ ] out which i think is
[ __ ] massively i think he's a good
good at like sort of finding that line
of like being honest not like [ __ ]
blowing smoke up anyone's ass yeah and
like just
you know but he had to kind of like
leave a lot of the edgy [ __ ] in the past
you know because his thing
was always just saying the craziest [ __ ]
to people and just making them react you
know
like he said to [ __ ] post malone he
said what are you doing to support black
lives matter at the very beginning of
post malone's career post malone like
obviously he kind of bumbled his answer
a little bit i don't think he said
anything like super
offensive but like you know he would
love to do that like he would always be
making people walk out on him and [ __ ]
and it's it has been kind of interesting
to see him like
fall back on that [ __ ] a little bit and
be a little bit more of just like a a
good interviewer you know you think
because the birdman [ __ ] came in
there was just like yo no i think he
doesn't want to get canceled i think
that charlemagne at a certain point
decided that he doesn't want to make the
woke people angry and he sort of fell in
line to a certain extent but i mean i
still i still respect it you know it's
like it's not for everybody to be edgy
for the rest of your career you know
sure he has kamala harris who's really
running the country and she acted like
she didn't hear him and she just dipped
yeah and in moments like that you are
like okay that's the old charlemagne
right there giving her a hard time yeah
she was classic with six nine
you know and that wasn't being edgy that
was just being like about six nine rand
[ __ ] circles around him in those
interviews that that actually was when i
realized how powerful of a communicator
69 was that i've always compared him to
donald trump in the sense that like he
just
is the biggest piece of [ __ ] but he
could just control the room and
everybody's attention you know and i've
when i saw 69 like not the first
interview but the second interview that
he did on breakfast club which as far as
i could tell is like the biggest rap
interview ever because on youtube
because i went and looked
because i was trying he said um he only
fears uh the feds yes but i went and
looked to see if it was the biggest
rapper interview of all time because i
thought my xxx cintastion interview
might have the most views of any rapper
interview ever on youtube but i think
that one has a little bit more but
either way like when you watch that
interview like charlemagne normally
controls the room in his interviews and
six nine is like
he's just running [ __ ] in that interview
and like they have three hosts and
they're kind of like powerless to stop
the energy of like what he was bringing
to that room you know and like that
doesn't exist anymore i've noticed
because i watched like other 69
interviews since then like since he
snitched and got off on the fed case or
whatever and it's it's not the same like
he's just he doesn't have the same charm
that he had before all that but i i mean
when he was at his heights it was insane
but when he was in that one interview
recently where he was just like yelling
like is he lacking like i don't even you
know and and yeah but he the reason why
he controlled the room was because he
was just like loud and aggressive and
like what do you do to them but in that
recent one that you're talking about i
think with uh it's like academics whack
100 uh
who's saying uh hassan campbell and then
him and it's like he's got some of his
like brooklyn goons like his gang
members that he's rolling around with
and everyone else is talking over him
it's like he just clearly doesn't
command the same like social status that
he had before so people aren't just
seating the floor to him in the
conversation that whole like godly
thing that he had going on is gone which
is pretty [ __ ] crazy to me to just
watch that obs to observe that just sort
of like dissipate over time what's
lacking mean lacking is like if you're
outside without a gun and somebody runs
up on you and robs you then you were
lacking and then what's the stand tall
guy a he's talking stand-up guy he was
like you know it was pakistan tall guy
he said
i'm like what i don't know what these
means i don't know probably just like
maybe somebody that has a gun i would
think you're saying like basically that
you have a gun and if somebody runs up
on you and tries to disrespect you
you're going to shoot them that type of
thing because i think they were talking
about the situation with meek mill where
69 like ran up on meek mill outside a
club in miami right and like 6-9 had
security meek mill had security meek has
retired cops or like off-duty cops with
guns and everything and six nine
basically gets in his face and just
yells at him and disrespects him and
says a bunch of crazy [ __ ] and meek
basically was like [ __ ] like he yelled
back for a bit but then he was like [ __ ]
this and he walked off and
avoided the situation you know which is
to a lot of like gang members and stuff
they use this as like evidence that meek
mill's a [ __ ] because he refused to
you know do battle with six nine in this
situation which to me is like a person
who's more concerned with not going to
prison i'm like
i think meek mill did what he [ __ ]
was supposed to do i mean you got all
the security around you for a reason so
you don't have to entertain these
[ __ ] morons right right if a guy
comes up to me right now in the parking
lot and says hey man i'm tougher than
you boom bam boom whatever it's like
that's why i have a [ __ ] security
guard right over there so that i don't
have to listen to your dumb ass opinions
crazy and if you want to act tough or
you want to pull a gun out then he's
going to shoot you and
lol you know
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now
you can get the autographed copy so get
on it man pre-order my book it's not
going to waste your time because i'm
proven dude new york times bestseller my
first book's five star rated on amazon
and i have no doubt this one will be two
so get the autographed copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude